the NHL Tut boats game presented by
Cadillac Colleen McHugh Wayne Gretzky
Paul Business
yeah he sounded Henry gloveless but you
know what we're gonna go right back down
to the ice because Jack eichel joins us
right now Jack thanks so much for coming
on appreciate it congratulations an
unbelievable playoff run for you when
you joined this Vegas Golden ice team
when you came over to this side
is this what you dreamed about
yeah I I yeah I think this is what
everyone dreams of but uh you come to an
organization like this and the
expectation is to win this thing so it's
a special place to play and I just can't
give everyone enough credit for putting
us in this position and the guy's in the
room I mean it's like it's just the most
unselfish group in the world and
um it's pretty pretty good to do this
with them
congratulations women how does Jack
eichel Stanley Cup champion sound to you
sounds pretty good that sounds
unbelievable yeah it's uh it's tough to
put into words guys I mean it's it's
just pretty special
all right jack I hate to be a buzz kill
here buddy put that mic a little bit
closer to your mouse so the fans at home
can hear you sure yeah oh you're good
sorry I hate to be the buzz kill but
yeah I imagine it's gonna feel good I
want to talk about that chemistry with
your line Barbara seven of course March
told who ends up going to win the cards
fight how quickly did you guys gel
together when he came over at the
deadline as far as Barber Shop is
concerned and just talk about how fun of
a run it was for that line to get going
yeah I mean I think when uh when barbs
came over it was uh it was pretty
seamless uh I mean he's he's such an
easy player to play with and Marshy and
I took a little bit to get the chemistry
going and I think after the bye week we
uh we started to you know take off a
little bit and then he had a guy like
barbs and he was just so great in the
playoffs obviously he's done this in St
Louis he had that bit of experience to
our group and Marshy gets so hot and uh
I mean he went on a heck of a run and
you know so deserving of the cons
tonight I'm so happy for him he's been
here since the beginning and you know
they call him the Misfits you know those
guys are the guys that uh
you know they built this they built this
culture and just so proud to be a part
of it Jack Ace One More there's so many
options here in Vegas where's the first
stop the cup is going tonight
um I don't know
um I'm sure I'm sure someone has
something planned and
um we're gonna enjoy this one guys
all right thanks so much congratulations
enjoy tonight all right thank you guys
thank you congrats all right that was
probably uh the only mistake he made in
the five games didn't have the
microphone
but it's got to be so special for the
guy now well listen he came here with a
lot of pressure he went to Buffalo a lot
of pressure hurt his neck went through
all that turmoil he hung in there like I
said Vegas was looking for that one key
player that got him Buffalo got some
nice parts so it was a good trade for
both teams
that's a sign of a Stanley Cup champion
though I mean you could have talked
about Jack eichel when mccon Smith Aiden
Hill Marsha soul Mark Stone one player
isn't enough to Hoist the Stanley Cup
you need to have a lot of guys there
gretson yeah this Vegas gold Knights
team was really deep well I I can't
remember a team that really didn't have
a weakness I mean their fourth line is a
line that they dumped the puck in they
took their man they're well positioned
they didn't give up goals against uh the
other three lines played well and we
talked about the six defenseman my
goodness they just kept rotating throw
the next pair out throw the next pair
out and they played within themselves
they didn't take penalties right they
didn't there was no parade to the
Penalty Box and yet they still played
very physical I think that was the most
impressive part about their game in this
series how locked in they were right to
their process of winning games obviously
it starts with coaching but also the
commitment within the group to agree on
we need to do these things to have
success and you didn't seem many
mistakes third period here yeah it
started to open up a little bit because
there were up five holes but you look at
these games that that's what impresses
me the most just the commitment to every
little detail within the game and they
were just so hard to to play against and
then look at Florida being beat up and
a couple key guys being heard obviously
made the task even tougher but wow what
what an impressive team performance by
Vegas big time they couldn't get rattled
either you know obviously Florida trying
to come in scrub it up they stayed
disciplined to that uh that tough loss
in game three and how they bounced back
where they didn't let that affect them
uh you guys just mentioned it line after
line and the depth really played a huge
factor and one cool moment that we got
to see uh uh it was Riley Smith and
March of Soul embracing you know these
are two guys who were let go by that
Florida panther team and and that
rejection and that pain and then of
course Marshall being asked about going
through that first cup run and what he
was left left with but you know
sometimes losses can teach you a lot
about yourself and the way that this
team was able to bounce back with the
original from mitzvitz along with those
other guys added was a made for a very
very special run and the gold meds
continue to break the rules and create
their own rules Liam how many times have
we done this and looks like the whole
building's on the ice I've never seen
this before yeah celebration have you
had the whole building on the ice ever
let me tell you something the first
three Stanley Cups we won
there was really nobody knew what to do
and the people just piled onto the ice
and you couldn't move I remember we were
coming back in Edmonton we're up three
games tonight and I said listen don't
let anybody on the ice and the the
fourth cup I was part of there was
nobody on the ice and that's when I sat
there and I said hey we got to get a
team picture like they used to do in the
50s and 60s and that's how it came about
because all the security guys kept the
fans off the ice and the fans liked it
better because the guys in those days we
all skated together in a group you
didn't hand it to one guy right we all
skated together and so we skated around
the rink a couple times and then we took
the picture and people loved it
but this is such a cool team we on the
ice now we saw the players handing the
cup to each other but now the families
are out there they get to enjoy it as
well Jonathan Marshall so the con Smythe
winner playoff MVP's been miked up for
us throughout the night let's take a
look at what he was experiencing
[Applause]
[Music]
I didn't want to tell you but when I saw
my vision of winning the cup we weren't
having we didn't have the white jerseys
[Applause]
hi hi bro
hey skip
you can't touch that one
touch it
hey grass man
[Applause]
for me it's the best thing I've ever
seen
oh my God I almost dropped it hey hey
somebody help out somebody help Brent
it's heavy
oh my God
oh God
are we there guys I'm so happy can you
believe this I'm so happy oh my God
would it like to be alive awesome what a
time to be alive let's I I love the fact
that uh he told Jackie uh he's not sure
what he's doing but he's not gonna be
sleeping
but also just the idea he won the con
Smite and you look around at how happy
everyone else was for him in that moment
you know when you win the Stanley Cup
the players aren't thinking about the
cons tonight I remember we won in 87 it
wasn't for about an hour and a half
somebody said in the locker room who won
the cons Smite and Ron Hextall on the
other team won it we didn't even know
because that's not what you're thinking
about that's how you're focused on and
for him to win that you could see how
happy his players and his teammates were
for him and listen he
he went through the thing he had to go
through that let go by Florida
but he also has that chip on the
shoulder because I know that feeling
because he's a small guy and people say
he can't play he's too small he can't
play he's too small it's great to see
guys like that it just shows kids if you
got heart doesn't matter how big you're
if you got a heart you can play in the
NHL you know I love our sport too gretz
last night in the hotel room I'm sitting
there watching the NBA and the first
person that touches the trophy is the
owner for the Denver Nuggets with hockey
the first person that touches the trophy
is the Players yeah I know the ownership
group here in in Vegas and all the teams
that have won ownership is so important
but it's the players that are battling
on the ice so I love seeing guys get the
opportunity to hoist that trophy trophy
first and then management comes after
absolutely and Hank will tell you this
it's good to see the families on the ice
because those wives and those kids they
don't see their dads or husbands for two
months like it's a tournament and I've
said this before to become a champion
you got to be really selfish and I mean
not in a good way it means that you got
to just focus on each and every game and
your spouse and your family has to be
part of that too and they have to
realize listen this this is the big two
months for my husband and that's why
they deserve to be on the ice and when
team goes on long runs like this the
best part in my mind
you've become even closer you heard
couple players touch on in here in the
interviews but just how much you go
through together as a group and and the
ups and downs and the momentum swings
it's emotional it's you feel the
pressure anxiety and excitement but you
go through so much and when you have
great runs with teams you become really
close and
that was the one thing I loved moving on
from regular season into playoffs
suddenly you can feel it in the room it
was about winning it was about coming
together during the regular season was a
little more focused on ice time and
who's getting on the power play but
suddenly when you start the playoffs it
was all about coming together and win
and that feeling was just amazing to
have in the locker room congrats you
talk about the families you sacrificed
the routes and these are those moments
now that you can cherish you look back
years later at some of these pictures
baby pictures with the cup but you
mentioned it Hank Mark Stone said it
it's so special because I won the cup
with 25 of my best friends
and this is a tight group
from the guys that were brought in like
eichel like Stone like petrangelo to all
the Misfits who started here incredible
and I was just going to ask quickly
Wayne Uh were you a little stunned at
the weight of the cup when you first
grabbed it I was shocked you know when
you're playing the pops you'd lose
weight right so I think I was about 155
pounds the first time I lifted the cup I
almost dropped it it never worked out
anyways thank God Kevin a mess for
standing is that why you started doing
all those push-ups and I can do 12 now
it's that core string I love it what a
moment no problem for these guys lifting
it right now Vegas golden knights
Stanley Cup champs